on Prime crime what I am doing is
[Music]
I'm looking at myself so negatively
the struggles of a teenager take Center
Stage I was just scared for him because
I had a feeling that this would come up
at some point the case that changed
everything this case made a tremendous
impact when words become deadly
tonight is the night it's now or never
you better not be mean say you're going
to do this then purposely get caught
foreign
[Music]
everybody I'm Jesse Weber and welcome to
prime prime this is where we do a deeper
dive into the most high profile and
memorable True Crime cases this next
story is both painful as it is
unprecedented and has shaped the legal
World in a Monumental way
matapoisett Massachusetts a small
Waterfront town that back in 2014 was
the home of 18 year old Conrad Roy a
young man who enjoyed boating and the
Red Sox and whom his family
affectionately called Coco yet
Underneath It All Roy was struggling
hi this is Conrad Henry rui III
reporting to you about what's going on
through my mind what's going on through
my head the last few days
[Music]
what I am doing is
I'm looking at myself so negatively I
thought I'd had gone through a number of
issues his parents divorced there was
allegedly some domestic violence in
their relationship his grades were
really struggling in school he had a
history of depression and anxiety in
fact he had been hospitalized previously
for a suicide attempt
looking myself I'm in the school little
particle
the base of this Earth
it's no good trash will never be
successful
and have a life never have
the kids never
learn
but I have a lot to offer someone
in 2012 during a trip to Florida Roy
meets Michelle Carter a girl a year
younger than him and who lived in
Plainville Massachusetts on the outside
she seemed to be a happy and nice person
however like Roy she suffered internally
as well Michelle allegedly had a history
of depression as well as a pretty
significant eating disorder Michelle
believed that she didn't have a lot of
friends she didn't believe that she was
well liked yet she was voted Class Clown
she was voted most likely to brighten
your day there was a discrepancy between
what she was feeling with this
depression and what was actually going
on in reality
Carter and Roy became boyfriend and
girlfriend but it wasn't a typical
relationship in the two years of dating
they communicated primarily through
online messaging or on the phone and
even though Carter lived just an hour
away from Roy the two met in person only
a handful of times in fact there are no
documented photos of them together
they really bonded over their mental
health struggles
it's almost like a trauma Bond really
kind of this pessimistic mindset when
they were talking about all of their
struggles and this can be incredibly
toxic and create codependency in a
relationship I found the relationship
rather tragic when you have two
individuals who are both vulnerable for
different reasons who both have been
through different traumas who both
really are fragile it can have tragic
consequences a lot of people tell me
that I have a lot going for me
I have to be happy I have to be happy
well no you don't have to be happy
what goes
happiness comes from
your conscious
thoughts
July 12 2014 exactly one month after Roy
records himself on video
he drives to a Kmart in Fairhaven
Massachusetts he parks in the lot rolls
the windows up and then proceeds to
power on a water pump filling his truck
with carbon monoxide and what is
believed to have taken several minutes
the poisonous fumes overtake him and
Conrad Roy eventually dies
anytime
teenagers anyone miners they die it's a
tragedy whether they die through in
being involved in some act or whether
it's suicide whatever it is it's so sad
it feels like once again we have failed
our youth the investigation reveals that
before his death Roy left notes to his
family and Carter Carter herself appears
devastated attending Roy's funeral and
wake bonding with his family texting
friends over her loss and even
organizing a baseball fundraiser in
Roy's name
law enforcement believe this is a case
of a typical suicide that is until they
review Roy's phone we can record the
conversation you're 18 years old right
so you could talk to us all right
detectives decide to interview Michelle
Carter at her high school we were
looking into Conrad's unfortunate
passing that we did determine a little
bit that you probably you probably had a
lot of contact with them
yeah
um maybe even right up until
pretty close to the time in which maybe
he stopped having contact with anybody
coming up we're about to learn there's a
lot more behind Conrad Roy's death than
anyone could ever have imagined
[Music]
I'm introverted
nice and Karen and some benefits I'm a
nice kid
but it's comes to a point
where I'm just
too nice
in July 2014 18 year old Conrad Roy is
found dead inside his car it's
determined he killed himself through
carbon monoxide poisoning for a young
man who suffered from depression and
anxiety at first this appears to be an
everyday suicide however authorities
start taking a closer look at Roy's
girlfriend Michelle Carter
did he tell you he was gonna do that or
anything like that
um
he was talking about it for a while and
you told me
that
um
like no one would be able to help him
Roy and Carter's relationship was
primarily dominated and documented
through text aside from professing their
love for one another those messages did
reveal that Roy was contemplating taking
his own life and at first the then 17
year old Carter appeared to try to
convince him otherwise
awesome guys from that I loved him and I
told him that a lot of people loved him
yeah and
that like without him nothing would be
the same and I told him that and he
should come with me and get the help
that he needed but he he refused there's
only one problem with Carter's interview
with police
she left out some very important details
police figured out her role in his death
by obtaining his cell phone my goodness
they found just all these messages are
involving this young man's death and
encouraging him or pushing him to take
his own life to the shock of the world
these messages show that in the time
leading up to Roy's death Carter
motivated Roy to kill himself in one
text Carter said you're finally going to
be in heaven no more pain no more bad
thoughts and worries you'll be free
in others she scolded Roy saying you're
gonna have to prove me wrong because I
just don't think you really want this
and if you don't try something you're
just gonna get worse and worse and I
don't think you can get any worse at
this point
I took his life through carbon monoxide
poisoning this method of suicide is
incredibly uncommon when it comes to
adolescence
did you have contact on the day right up
until
he he passed I think so in fact Carter
and Roy texted throughout the entire day
of his death and despite Roy's hesitancy
Carter was pressuring him even further
she wrote you keep pushing it off and
say you'll do it but never do it's
always going to be that way if you don't
take action in another text Carter says
you're ready and prepared all you have
to do is turn the generator on and
you'll be free and happy
in one of their final exchanges Carter
writes so it's time
she just consistently
consistently badgered him uh and and
came very close to belittling him for
not being able to stand up and take this
action
all the way up until the day of his
death and that's not even the worst part
it's been alleged that Roy at the last
minute backed out of the plan and got
out of his truck yet when he spoke to
Carter on the phone she told him to get
back in and kill himself
Carter is believed to have stayed on the
line as she heard Roy die
she is the instrument basically uh that
caused the death she didn't have
um and like a knife but rather she was
the weapon she speaking to him and what
she was telling him and her words were
the weapon that caused his death in this
scenario the question is why why would
Carter do this I think what she had to
gain by this was attention
people would see her as helpless as this
grieving girlfriend that just went
through something incredibly traumatic
and rushed to her Aid and that is
exactly what happened I was trying to
get it helped warm sooner I like want
him to go with me and I I should have
done something sooner but
another time
it's important to remember one other
point about Conrad Roy before his
suicide he did something very
interesting he deleted all text messages
on his phone except those from her
that's a very calculated move
was it that he wanted to leave
breadcrumbs so someone would know why he
did not so much why he did this but how
he got to this point we'll never know
but that's quite possible after the
details of the teens conversations are
on Earth by investigators Michelle
Carter is indicted on a charge of
involuntary manslaughter for Conrad
Roy's death this is a groundbreaking
move and presents what many Saw as a
novel legal question our words alone
criminal more when we return
we have a search warrant for your phone
okay so we'll be taking it
Massachusetts
2015. Michelle Carter is charged with
involuntary manslaughter in connection
with the death of her boyfriend Conrad
Roy at the time the then 17 year old
allegedly encouraged Roy to kill himself
the government argued that she pressured
him through a series of text messages
and even gave him one final push by
speaking to him on the phone right at
the moment of his suicide this presents
a controversially landmark case can
someone be criminally liable for the
killing of another through conversations
alone especially when Carter was miles
away from Roy when he died in this
particular case it was the weight of the
evidence the numerous text messages
tended to show that she certainly knew
he had this result and that she almost
pushed him into it
on the other hand was Carter really to
blame Conrad Roy was suicidal and he had
attempted to kill himself on another
occasion depression
or social it can mean you don't like
yourself
and the sooner I like myself
the better I'm going to be
the primary argument against this being
manslaughter was that this was not
encouragement it was an endorsement of
an existing plan this young man
unfortunately would have committed
suicide whether she opened her mouth or
not Carter ended up making a unique
Choice with respect to her case
instead of having a jury decide her
guilt she opted for a bench trial
in a bench trial the judge is acting as
the jury and weighing all the evidence
when you have a jury trial it
statistically is a little bit easier
because you only have to convince one
out of 12 that there's Reasonable Doubt
on the other hand the judge ostensibly
understands the law the nuances of the
law and might exercise a little more
discretion that may perhaps work in your
favor when you have a new type of case
which this is
on June 6 2017 that trial began
the prosecution came out strong
tonight is the night it's now or never
when he delayed she expressed
frustration and even anger
you better not be mean say you're going
to do this then purposely get caught
the defense argued this wasn't Carter's
fault
the cause of his death was not Michelle
Carter the cause of his death was a
suicide but Michelle had a strong
defense so her relative youth mental
health history were primary factors in
her defense Carter's lawyers even
suggested that antidepressants caused
her to become delusional and to believe
she was actually helping Roy
there are a lot of people that are
prescribed psychotropic medications
especially the ones that Michelle was
prescribed which are very commonly
prescribed antidepressants the defense
tried to argue that these medications
induced Mania for Michelle
these medications are very safe they
very rarely will induce Mania
when we come back the incredible
conclusion of Michelle Carter's trial
Court shows are the same we're talking
about your father guilty or not guilty
guilty think again judge Caprio rules
with common sense I was having
contractions I was rushing to the
hospital inspector Quinn what does
Justice demand jail and compassion I'm
going to take the circumstances into
consideration the best court experience
I've had clearly judge he's been in a
court before get caught in Providence
hi I'm Dan Abrams in the exploding legal
and True Crime genre long crime is the
only Network that has it all good
evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't really jump to
conclusions welcome to Prime crime
tonight another day of drama between
both sides from multiple live trials
daily to original and compelling
programming the long crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box this is long crime
the night before the 12th and we were
talking and then
like the phone like hung up but I didn't
I didn't really think anything of it but
then the next morning his mom called me
and said like I can't find Conrad in
2017 Michelle Carter is on trial for
involuntary manslaughter of her
boyfriend Conrad Roy through their text
message and phone call history
prosecutors argued that when she was 17
she psychologically pressured Roy to
kill himself by carbon monoxide
poisoning in his truck even though she
was miles away at the time of his death
the defense argued that Carter was not
to blame in that Roy was already
suicidal and Carter's mental health age
and use of antidepressants alleviated
criminal responsibility
are words alone criminal Carter decided
to not leave this complicated and
arguably unprecedented legal question in
the hands of a jury but rather a judge
with the world watching judge Lawrence
Moniz announced his verdict
however he breaks that chain of
self-causation
by exiting the vehicle
she instructs him to get back into the
truck
which she has reason to know
is or is becoming a toxic environment
inconsistent with human life
is kind of please stand
it's good
having reviewed the evidence and applied
to law there too
Now find you guilty on the indictment
charging you with the involuntary
manslaughter of the person Conrad Roy
III
her being on the phone with him at the
moment that he died that's really what
did her in that's what caused her
conviction but when she was on the phone
with him he literally at that moment was
contemplating whether he should go
through it with it or not and that's
when she just really pushed him over the
edge the state was asking for 7 to 12
years in prison the defense for only
five years probation another big
decision in the hands of Judge Moniz
now sentences you to two and a half
years in the Bristol County House of
Correction
15 months of said sentence shall be
deemed a committed sentence If This
truly was a homicide This truly was
manslaughter one would think the
sentence would be far longer and that
makes me wonder it was the judge trying
to split the difference here I think a
lot of people would say it's not the
right decision that type of sentence is
a much shorter sentence than we see in
most manslaughter cases
but it fits this unique set of facts
better on January 23 2020 Michelle
Carter was officially released from
prison
she was released uh by all indications
because she was a model prisoner she
worked assisted others
um and I also believe that she was
released because of her relative youth
my concern with Michelle being released
is that this was a high profile trial
she's going to have a dark cloud hanging
over her I don't believe that there was
malicious intent with her encouraging
Conrad to commit suicide and so I'm
hopeful that she has used this
opportunity to grow
but she's going to have to take
accountability for her actions and her
next boyfriend or girlfriend is going to
be in a very unique and scary position
Carter's own legal Journey may be over
but this case could be just the
beginning
this case made a tremendous impact in
the legal Community this case is all
about words and how Reckless can Words
Be You have to ask where does this end
this will not be the last case that we
see where someone will be arrested and
charged with some form of homicide
because solely of their words and the
lawyers will Point directly to this case
whatever effect this case will
ultimately have on the criminal justice
system this all started because of one
young man whose life ended much too soon
I I do have a lot going for me but I
just got a job from the Boston Taurus to
Captain their boat like that's a huge
accomplishment
he gave me an amazing 13 years being my
best friend and the best role model
any little sister could ask for
the last words I said to my son was I
love you
and Coco said I love you too
I miss him every moment of every day
I mean it's going to be difficult
to accomplish
but I need to for personal growth
accomplish this
sense of
self-pride in myself
the death of Conrad Roy is incredibly
sad but it's also important because his
case has changed the law forever and it
also may have brought more attention to
the sometimes overlooked issue of teen
suicide so for a young man who seemingly
questioned his significance in the world
he had an impact that will never be
forgotten
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime leave us your comments on
Instagram and Twitter with the hashtag
primecrime as always thank you for
joining us and until next time be safe
foreign
[Music]